all right rookies to rely on for the
rest of the season in other words the
biggest impact that they will make the
rest of the year for their teams trivia
question for chris
cowboy's rookie cd lamb is the second
player in nfl history with five or more
catches in each of his first five career
games who was the first here's a hint he
did eventually play for the cowboys but
was not drafted by them
wow
okay
um
keyshawn johnson
[Music]
ah that is good i thought you're gonna
go joey galloway oh i didn't even think
of it i should have that one not him
terry glenn wow terry glenn man so he he
started up in new england tearing it up
right from the get-go i didn't really i
didn't realize he got off to that kind
of start
impressive yeah
now here's the challenge uh for this
draft because i'm looking at it from the
standpoint of contending teams like hey
i got faith in justin herbert but the
team's one and four like what like i i
want to put my money on a rookie
who is with a team where he's going to
make a difference and he's going to make
something happen and he's going to be
playing in january and this is hey look
chase clay pulls the flavor of the month
the flavor of the week he had four
touchdowns there's no reason to think
all of a sudden those skills that caused
him to have four touchdowns are going to
go away i'm going chase claypool because
his team's 4-0
and the arrow is pointing up for this
kid yeah and chris sims has been telling
you about him since last freaking april
and and i've been listening to you i
know yeah well hopefully that will be
the
the you know big shot that across the
bow for pittsburgh to finally go okay we
trust you just like we heard chase
claypool big ben can say we trust you
and now they make him the guy i mean
they should you know again it's easy for
me to say here on the outside looking in
we don't know where he is in the offense
and all the checks and all those type of
things but
i mean
the the physical ability and what you
see on the field there's nobody on the
steelers that has his talent level at
the wide receiver position so i'm hoping
they make him the go-to guy you see he's
special um good for you
all right i'm gonna go with henry ruggs
then i'm gonna go to another receiver i
mean ruggs is a guy yeah you see they're
a different football team when he's on
the field he opens it all up he's
dangerous as hell i've never seen a guy
who's so fast who makes it look like
he's jogging or just striding it out but
no one gains ground on him and then he
plays big too i mean we saw in the first
drive of the game last week he goes up
and jumps up in the air and catches a
50-50 ball at his size so
he's a guy that i look at right now and
go yeah trust him
give him the ball more raiders and
however that is more speed sweeps
whatever but i think he's a guy we can
depend on i'm kind of sold on that from
what i've seen so far
i'm gonna go with the guy who was the
subject of our trivia question another
receiver three for three on receivers
the cowboys are are very much alive to
win their division they would be out of
the mix in most other divisions but at
two and three they're in first place
and look andy dalton has taken a team to
five straight playoff berths in the past
and he's got a group of receivers like
he's never had before in amari cooper
c.d lam michael gallup cedric wilson and
c.d lamp has done uh great things so far
so you know as the cowboys make their
push for a playoff berth with a lot less
pressure on them given the quarterback
change i i'll take cd lamp yeah i get
that too i mean he's he's a pro and you
can see i mean his play-making ability
the way he looks it just gets better
every week um he is he's awesome and
they they can make him the focal point
of their offense they certainly could
and not miss a beat i'm gonna go with
justin herbert i am
you know for for for here's and here's
for the two reasons because what you
said is very real you want to be able to
like pick a guy i know what you're
saying like where you feel like hey this
team has a chance and like we're talking
about rookies who have an impact
impacting like you're going to help that
team win and and make them relevant all
right well i'm picking herbert because
i'm saying hey chargers take the
training wheels off and i mean not on
justin herbert his or off you coaches
take them off like stop with the first
down run second down run oh we're we're
managing our quarterback oh yeah what
managing so much you put him in third
and 12 and then you ask him to make i
mean the chargers can't run the ball
give it up what are you managing anymore
your running backs are average is
dishwater your o-line is average
like move on
he's the star open up the game you're
doing a disservice to him right now part
of the reasons they've lost the last few
weeks is because they get leads and then
they manage the game to where they're
like hey guys we're winning by too much
we'd like the other team to come back a
little bit so we're gonna like totally
sit on the ball and do nothing now so
they can come back like stop that crap
they have a chance still the jaguars the
broncos the dolphins the jets those are
four to the next five
teams they play they can win those four
games and then be right back in the mix
of things
why did you use the word dishwater again
i don't know i heard an old coach that
said it's average as dishwater he used
to say it and i just used it i don't
know
i had a flashback right i had a
flashback
uh to the 70s
when from time to time i was relegated
the task of doing the dishes against my
will right and dishwater is nasty did
you want the stuff that gets in there
especially if you don't rinse the plates
before you do it when you only have one
sink you know this is the age if
everyone has two sinks yeah back in the
70s you had one sink so it's not like
you could rinse the plates wow you had
to do all the rinsing before you compa
you know i didn't know what the hell i
was doing so you'd have spaghetti in
there i mean dishwater was nasty so try
not to let's not put dishwater on the
pft bingo were you a bad boy ever and
your mom had to put soap in your mouth
is that a thing like at all in your
livelihood
um it wasn't soap it was a wooden spoon
on your butt wooden spoon paddle a piece
of molding that you know she just
happened to think hey this will be nice
oh and that was the way it was italian
moms love the wooden spoon what is that
all my friends growing up all that they
it was the italian moms love the wooden
spoon and chasing their kids out there
with that but let me tell you this let
me tell you this you may be shocked to
know this i was a smart ass
you what and uh i was a smart ass when i
was a kid
and and i would do the calculation in my
brain
of here's this zinger i want to throw at
mom
is it worth getting my ass beat over it
and sometimes i'd say no
sometimes i'd say yes
so
sometimes i just like you know what i
can't let this line go
it's g it's got to be used it can't be
forfeited to history even if i have a
welt on my butt for the rest of the
night but that's the way it was and that
was the way they disciplined and uh you
know it didn't work i eventually figured
out the connection between being a smart
ass and getting whipped and i decided to
stop being a smart ass until i became an
adult and chris and pete is telling me
to keep moving and we're gonna run out
of time next one for me patrick queen
defensive player of the week for the afc
this week and uh maybe that maybe the
cure to the kryptonite that is the
kansas city chiefs even when if and when
they cross paths again chris in the
postseason he's been great at linebacker
for the ravens and and to go against his
old quarterback and to have the
performance he did i think that's one of
those things that's going to give
patrick queen even more of a lift for
the rest of the season but it's all for
the ravens setting up for when they see
the chiefs again and maybe queen will be
dramatically better when they
face kansas city the second time around
if that yeah well he is he's special i
mean he flies around the field i mean
you when you watch baltimore raven's
film you see him he pops out a lot all
right i'm i'm still gonna i'm gonna go
with clyde edward solaire for my last
one because i still think there's ways
they can use him more you know more in
the screen game more as a slot receiver
doing things like that expand his role i
think he's shown he's perfectly reliable
he seems very mature seems to have a
grasp of the offense when you read
things that they say out there about him
and all of that to where i think there
is a spot for more of a role especially
when we talk about those teams who play
soft coverages him underneath and all
the screens and everything uh i think
it'd still be very effective
he had 80 total yards in the game
against the raiders and he's gone from
138
the the leading rusher week one
down to 38 64 64 and 40. now
he's he's added more he's added more uh
yards in the passing game but you know
it's not the kind of impact that we
thought and we mentioned le'veon bell
chris yeah the chiefs were interested
last year they were interested in adrian
peterson right frankly uh maybe they're
going to be interested in le'veon bell
once he's cut by the jets all right they
want to show the bingo did we hit a
bingo today anybody got a bing bingo do
we have a bingo no bingo today
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports